so let's talk about your book that's
what my book is actually on these sorts
of topics
exactly the book is speechless
controlling words
controlling minds as i you may have
heard of it before i think i have
someone super super chatted yeah did
they one or two yeah yeah a couple of
people i think uh chat
i do i have to thank i truly need to
thank
the viewers of this show you
uh seriously if this book makes the list
if this book if the new york times is
forced to put this on the list
if which i don't think they would do it
willingly but you know if they were
forced
if this book changes the conversation it
is because of the
insane viewers of this show
well they're fans of you i know it's
wonderful but i'll say it a million
times
you know reading reading the super chats
was fun i want people to buy your book i
want people to buy michael malus's book
andy nose book a bench of hero books
james o'keefe books
i want it so that when you go to
amazon.com and you click book
the top 10 are from anti-establishment
anti-woke
or just maybe voices you haven't heard
of yeah because for a long period what
were the top books
like uh white fragility oh yeah right
and so what happens is regular people
this
this is part of the information where
you're trying to explain to people your
ideas
and win hearts and win mines you know it
was a big one was becoming michelle
obama
which i thought i don't know if you've
seen the conspiracy theory oh there's
this conspiracy theory of
talking about transgenderism and i just
thought if you're trying to tamp down
that conspiracy theory
don't title your book becoming a jello
ball that's not a good idea
anyway you gotta ignore the the weird
stuff to be honest that one's i know
what
it's pretty it's pretty out there i
don't i do not i know a guy who's like
dude i swear i watch these videos i'm
like i know that guy
[Music]
this was hotly debated we went back and
forth because
some people some people believed that to
sell the book
we needed one of these kind of sticky
covers where i'm like winking or
something and you know
whatever i'm you know but i just thought
no i i actually am making an argument
here i don't
ever intend to write a book again it's
simply too much work i'm gonna i'm just
only writing blank books from now on
that's good
going back to my original yes magnum
opus
but i do want to make this argument here
because i just feel like i mean
kind of the central point of the book is
whatever we have done
to push back against woke-ism has
advanced woke-ism isn't that weird it's
just anything either we
obviously when you get into it it
advances it but even when we push back
really hard against it
still it advances it and it's because of
tim actually a lot of what you've been
saying tonight
which is we just don't have any
standards and we're not willing to
articulate them but it's not it's not
enough to point that out
because you actually then have to
articulate
what the standard is and uh that is not
always popular this is why
years ago i began a lot of people would
describe the
the leftists as intersectionalists or
feminists and i started calling them
identitarians
yeah because identitarian is typically
used by white identitarians
now identitarianism just means like
identity and government so it's policy
predicated upon your identity
of course the white identitarians really
loved using it and i said that's the
exact same thing as the critical race
theory stuff
and so i'm going to as someone who
doesn't like either i'll refer to them
all under the same name
i had a conversation with uh i had a
conversation with a friend who's like a
very prom
like a very prominent activist very you
know woke
and i just always refer to them as an
identitarian
it puts them in the same camp as the
white nationalists
they hate it but it's true do you have
to get more
i mean i like this point because i you
know you have described
what the the conservatives keep messing
up which is they keep using the left's
own language
just before you don't forget that i just
want to make the simplified point
if you have a a red battlefield in a
blue battlefield
and you bring everyone onto the red
battlefield and say
red is the worst choice it's the only
thing that people are experiencing and
the only thing they'll talk about
yeah they won't even have an experience
of blue yeah you need to bring people to
your battlefield and make the left come
there to argue with you
so that instead of learning about
critical race theory they're learning
about
classical liberalism or conservative
values and making the left argue against
those preferably even the more
conservative ones
right you know i mean but it raises this
identity question because
you're not saying we can't have any kind
of identity obviously everybody's got an
identity i got my name
i got my religion i got my town i got my
state i got my country
that's an identity so your calling out
in particular would seem
this racial identity maybe this kind of
crazy gender identity
but it does leave this question open for
you which
is what we were talking about earlier in
the show
who are we as a country and who am i
personally and i've got
an old school catholic answer for you my
friends thank you
i've got finally here it is okay in the
bible
abraham moses rather asks god who are
you
what does god say i am i am i am
who i am i am who i am the essence of
being and
when you identify in that it's very easy
to
know who you are when you turn away from
that
well what am i i'm uh i'm i'm black i'm
uh
i'm a black lesbian a muslim uh ableist
syspan trans damn
white catholic van halen yeah like it
doesn't
and you know it's really pathetic it's
what little it's what kids do when they
try on different different identities
but in order to recover that sense of a
national identity
you have to say certain things that are
exclusive claims
this is who we are and if we say this is
who we are it's like a nation with a
border
if we say this is the nation then it
means outside the name then that's not
the nation
if this identity in america and you
might say it's
the classical liberal idea or it's this
or it's out of the other thing but if we
say this is what it is
then what we are saying is if you don't
go along with that you are not an
american
you are excluded you are ostracized you
might be outright censored
are we willing to make that kind of a
claim
one of the challenges that we've been
talking about for a while is that in
wartime
some of our greatest leaders did
horrifying things we talked about
abraham lincoln and we're we're so happy
the north won but
the dude suspended habeas corpus there's
the the rumor that he tried to get a
supreme court justice
uh arrested he did a lot of really bad
things he threatened the press
were they were they bad threatening the
press i mean these days that's i think
you should win the nobel peace prize for
that but uh
but it's it's it's doing what has to be
done to to
win and if we saw that happening today
if like donald trump
you know when he threatens the press the
media shrieks and howls
if uh if in order to win a war our civil
rights were curtailed we would be
furious 50 to 100 years on and it was
the right thing to do
sure and uh obviously there's a double
standard because you've got
the obama administration hounding the
press and harassing them
they obviously face no no consequences
for that
so yes we've become much more but i
guess this gets to my point
we've become much more individualistic
we've become much more
jealous about our individual some might
say licentious
autonomy to and we've totally lost a
sense of what brings us together you
know a republic
refers to the things we have in common
right the public things that we've got
we've got together
so if the left has lost that because
they've become insanely individualistic
on the
social side basically they want to have
sex with whoever they want to have sex
with or whatever
right and if the conservatives have
become insanely individualistic
on for a long time the economic side but
on certain aspects of
of cherished civil liberties and nobody
is paying any attention to what we have
to do together
what you have to sacrifice what you have
to suppress what you have to tamp down
in order to have a country together then
obviously the country is going to fizzle
and balkanize well
this is why right balkanization is is is
a best way to talk about the balkan
peninsula which is like the gr the greek
peninsula north of greece where it was
like shattered into like croatia
and all these different little countries
and continues to shatter and i think
i think people have mentioned peaceful
divorce but there have been many
individuals for years have been calling
for
you know more extremists calling for
balkanization of the us yeah and name a
peaceful
national divorce that has ever taken
place in history
you know it's the roman republic split
the roman empire split into the eastern
and western empire of course then that
caused
wars for years hundreds of years yeah
think about what's happening in the u.s
and as you mentioned conservatives are
too individualistic yeah
so they're not banding together the way
the left is the left is overly
a collectivist but the scary thing is
they have this insane moral ideology
and so then you're the libertarians yeah
you know and they're in their space
so what happens well a bunch of states
start saying
texas for instance we're going to do
what we want to do have a nice day
yeah and joe biden when he comes out and
speaks is clearly not talking to
uh texas or florida yeah when you're
saying earlier in the year like oh we
gotta we gotta double down on masks and
we gotta
we gotta put more restrictions in place
texas and florida were open so who was
he talking to clearly not them
and that's what's gonna keep happening
it's not so much that conservatives are
necessarily too individualistic it's
just that
the tribe of conservatives is made up of
a bunch of smaller tribes
yes but they have no reason to come
together i mean there was a moment it's
called fusionism this was the post-cold
work
or post-world war ii conservative
movement where bill buckley and frank
meyer and others
brought together the libertarians and
the traditionalists and the
warhawk dems you know and later on the
neoconservatives to come and
and fight against the soviet union
soviet union goes away
what exactly is uniting the
conservatives with the libertarians they
have
completely different accounts of human
nature they all usually want rather
different things as a matter of policy
why they when you consider the other
aspects the
neoconservatives and others they all
broke apart during 2016.
like what what is the coalition taxation
anti-woke
yeah yeah and i hope anti-woke is the
answer
but i fear ian you're right i think the
only thing they ever agree on
is cut taxes that's and i like i like
tax cuts but i think anti-woke is a
massive component of it
and it's probably because i'm biased
because i hope you're right
i'm i'm not the most uh like lower the
taxes kind of individual
um i was talking to bannon the other day
i agree with him he says raise the taxes
on the rich
the one problem i said is giving
government money i don't know if that's
the answer to the problems
but we just need to eat the rich it's
amazing how the politics have really
realigned here yeah um but you know
everyone's always trying to find what
the dividing line is i don't think
there's one but there's
and there are many the media lies do you
believe
cnn or do you disbelieve do you think
they're lying well i think
that is a core component the matrix are
out of the matrix could be easily
describe it
and then i also think what resante will
cause is a very uh
core aspect of that as well because you
turn on msnbc and they say republicans
don't want to teach your children about
slavery
which is lie insane right absolute lies
yeah
and so do you believe the lies or do you
are you seeing reality and that's why
it's funny that's why they say it's red
pill but hasn't the
i guess i fear the balkanization has
already happened and we're just
realizing it
you saw the secretary of state anthony
blinken is now flying
the progress flag at u.s embassies
around the world this is a new
this thing was invented like five
minutes ago and it's like the gay flag
with some other racial things and
transgender or something on it
but that is the new flag of the united
states that is
rather i'll be more specific that is the
flag of the liberal empire
so obviously the state department the
steward of the liberal empire is going
to fly it all around the world
the american flag makes claims about
america the the pride flag or
even the blm flag makes universal claims
about everywhere on earth
and when you look at twitter accounts
when you look at people's homes even
conservatives will fly the american flag
libs will fly the pride flag right those
are those are two different flags
ostensibly for the same country
but it's really now two countries kind
of living together
and these major corporations will change
their avatars to the pride flag
unless they're the saudi arabian bridge
yeah that's true it's amazing do they
not have
they can't edit their twitter i guess
over in qatar maybe oh strange
well i actually think it might be
illegal no joke yeah so they they
literally can't do it
sure and and i wonder i mean there's
such a push back against
the kind of craziness of the lgbt
trancing the kids drag queen story hour
but the elites and the elite
institutions are all pushing this i mean
that
that is the new national identity so if
you're giving an account of what america
is i fear
that the pride flag as a matter of our
actual governing institutions
is more representative i'll tell you uh
my issue with with the the embassy's
flying
flags other than the united states yeah
it
we we are the united states that is the
country that is the constitution is the
declaration of independence
you don't have to like the country
you're free to not like it but you are
in america you are governed by the
american government with social security
card and all that stuff
that flag is of your country
but the american government is flying
the pride flag and that's where you see
that
they're flying the flag of 12 it's
between 8 and 12
of the country it is not the majority of
the left it is not the majority of
moderates
it is absolutely not basically any of
the conservatives very very few
when you look at this several years ago
but the hidden tribes uh study that came
out
of data i actually talked about hidden
tribes eight percent
eight percent of the us identifies as
progressive yeah they're flying the flag
of a
fringe fringe minority the american flag
represents
every american citizen the pride flag
you're allowed to like it
i got no issue but it certainly does not
represent the 92 percent of the country
of course that's the case but they want
to through the politics and the culture
to to transform that and
they they just got a new independence
day you know we're coming up on july 4th
also known as independence day
but now we have a new independence day
it's actually in the name of the bill
the juneteenth national independence day
act
this is a local tradition from galveston
when some random dude showed up and
mentioned that lincoln have freed the
slaves years earlier that slaves
actually weren't
legally freed until the 13th amendment
which was ratified months after that
but this random date was contrived
almost out of whole cloth by the left to
become
the new national independence day and
the republicans voted for it well i i
take issue if if the idea is to subvert
july 4th yeah but actually i i don't
take issue with juneteenth uh i'm i'm
down for it
if if look we have labor day you know
what i mean like
yeah holiday commemorating people who
work i guess this is my this is my
problem
because i see your point sure it's a fun
you know it's a good thing to free the
slaves so sure
i mean we honor those who shed blood a
lot of blood and
treasure grant said blood and treasure
was shed
to
memorial day was set up after the
assassination of lincoln specifically to
honor the dead of the civil war
and all that that war represented i've
noticed with
you mentioned labor day all of our
holidays they have to do with gratitude
all of them labor day it's the ordinary
american worker veterans day obviously
memorial day
christmas even new year's day we sing
about old lang zine you know we'll have
a cup of kindness yet
what about fourth of july fourth of july
obviously
gratitude to our our country and our
founding fathers and the country they
gave us
but juneteenth i find it bereft of
gratitude you hear it in the arguments
during the debate to ratify
juneteenth all of these congressmen
saying this is about the injustice
to never forget the evils of this
country and even barack obama when he
started mentioning juneteenth and he
said last year that juneteenth
is not about a victory juneteenth
is about the ever-long march toward
progress i think that's by the way why
they just picked this random event when
some dude showed up in texas
it's not commemorating anything real
it's just commemorating a middle period
in between two other events because it's
not about the victory
it's to remind you of the evils we've
come from and how far
we have we go but maybe they just
shouldn't frame it that way maybe it
should be framed as uh
uh it was uh the marshall showed up in
galveston
where some texans were holding uh slaves
long after the emancipation proclamation
and these were the last individuals
to to finally receive their freedom but
they still but it still wasn't
properly abolished until the 13th event
i i recognize that um
i i like the idea of more freedom the
better you know what i mean yeah i just
i'll tell you i'll tell you my issue
with it is they attached the the red
salute to it
now that is a very serious problem not
just the red so it was the red salute
in in black so it was also the black
nationalist hand
and also as and i couldn't tell this on
twitter but i think it colors
yeah where the knuckles gay i think they
think they have something no no no no no
no it was uh um
it was red green and white i think oh
the sort of black nationalist
is that what it is
you know the italians always have a
racial middle ground anyway yeah
i i i like the idea of uh of
celebrating you know the end of slavery
yeah
we all do it desperately needs a
branding makeover
but it wasn't i mean but but look at it
this way abolitionist or something
no i i think it's fine i think it's i
think it's fine
holiday named after a day or a month
it's so weird it's also there
is it june 13th 14th 18th that's very
confusing
i i i'm not worried about that i'm
worried about
the critical race theorists are they
hate everything
but they're like juneteenth no no as you
mentioned it was not a day of
celebration or gratitude it was
commemorate our anger i'm like yeah yeah
i'm not about that i think it should be
a day to celebrate our victory over
you know the amoral horrifying
institution of slavery but we
we agree on that i guess my own this
kind of gets back to what we were saying
earlier about
arguing about what the government should
be in theory or what and
what it is in practice i i agree with
you there could be a wonderful day to
celebrate the end of slavery and sort of
memorial day is that
though we don't really think of it that
way anymore but
the fact is the people who pushed for
juneteenth
and wrote the name of the bill and made
the debates for it and are celebrating
it and they're putting the blackfist
with the
right either gay or black power colors
on the knuckles
all of those guys view it and are
presenting it as this resent filled
anti-american day of reckoning and i
think uh yes
would that we could perceive it another
way but i i just and you're you're right
about memorial day there was a um
i i i didn't look at the story too much
but uh someone's mica got cut off he was
like a veteran
because he mentioned memorial day was
set up because of the civil war and had
to do with slavery
and then they were like no no we don't
want to have this he's out but but it
was true memorial day was
was was set up uh following what you
said was the after the assassination of
lincoln yeah
i mean very very shortly there so i i i
do think it's it's important to
um man this is this is tough right it's
uh as i often describe it great how many
grains of sand make a heap
it might not be a big deal to many
people they're like juneteenth is a
great holiday it celebrates the end of
slavery
and then you mentioned memorial day does
that yeah and and those who shed blood
to end it
real quick it's not that any one of one
of these
arguments debates or news stories is the
most important
but when you stack up ten thousand of
them you've now have a dramatic shift in
your culture
and ultimately how people live their
freedoms
this is how things are better or worse
it's death by a thousand cuts right or
all the sand on
but because i i agree with all the
people who are shrugging their shoulders
and saying oh man who cares
i don't you know it's no another day off
frankly it's not a day off for us right
it's a day off for some federal
employees but okay
fine they they they work so hard don't
they yeah but
the the who cares argument has a simple
answer
the left cares that's why they fought
tooth and nail to get this thing through
it's the same as the pronouns who cares
about the pronouns i wouldn't care about
the pronouns
except that the left really cares about
the pronouns because they know
that in these very seemingly trivial
things
you carry whole premises in the case of
the pronouns you carry the premise
that human nature has nothing to do with
our body and a man can be a woman in the
case of juneteenth you carry the premise
that the original independence day was a
fraud it was it was wicked
and we and the country is now in
juneteenth the country's evil and we
need to reckon
did you see there was one jurisdiction
that canceled their july fourth parade
over kovid
but they're having a g they had a
juneteenth celebration of course of
course i mean
the fourth of july parade that's
unnecessary and frankly it's even worse
than unnecessary but juneteenth
that's our nation's most sacred feast
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you